brothers and sisters
when i became a president in 2019 what
was felt at that time was that
we would need to go a long way with
poland because the atmosphere was cool
in our relations
in our attitudes to
each other
so that's how it was but i wanted to
go
this way the way towards the wands
as quickly as possible
we knew that by nature we are close to
each other both the ukrainians and the
poles i remember my first meetings with
andre duda from meeting to meeting
things were changing the coolness
disappeared
we understood each other
as a ukrainian with a pole as europeans
as friends
as parents who like their families and
understand that our children
should live
in the world of the same shared good
values that they are to live in a world
where nations are independent
where
there is freedom
where family is important
our there is no uh
room for
military aggression
it supposed uh
that number seven brings fortune well
ukraine has seven uh neighbors
does it bring us good fortune well the
whole world knows the answer today
and
the 78 russian children know it best
those who were killed in russian
military attacks
this is the neighbor who brought poverty
and war to our country
the neighbor
who acts without god's blessing
when there is someone who is brutal
in its attack
we need someone you can count on we can
count on when somebody attacks you you
need a friend who will reach out to you
in the early morning on the 24th of
february i had no doubt who such a
person would be who will tell me you
will not be left alone with your enemy
and indeed
this happened i am very grateful to my
polish brothers and sisters who are
supporting us who are with us and this
is not true
on the very first day of the war it was
clear that the ukrainians
it was clear both for the ukrainians and
the polls that there are no borders
between us uh
physical historical personal human
after
the 16 days of this war the ukrainian
duma
and uh
the ukrainians are uh
honor and ukrainian's pride and poland
support
help
us between our nations there is
peace peace between neighbors peace
between brothers
and i would like these words to also
be heard by our
neighbors bel-russians we are close to
each other we are neighbors
we should also be brothers with you with
better russians and of course
we will achieve that ladies and
gentlemen
our polish brothers and sisters
for a long time
many parties try to convince us that
poles and ukrainians are far from each
other and that they lead different
rights why did they do that let me
remind you the words of the former
president of poland le catinski said in
policy
we know very well today it's the georgia
tomorrow
the ukraine then the baltic states and
maybe then the turn count will come for
poland on the 24th of february
this terrible tomorrow that he was
talking about happened for ukraine
and today we are fighting
for the baltic states uh and for poland
so that they wouldn't have to face that
time
and we are fighting together together we
are 90 million people together we can do
everything this is a historical mission
of poland and of ukraine to be leaders
to be together
and to
take europe
from this precipice
and from this danger
to stop
europe from becoming a victim of this
aggression ladies and gentlemen we can
do it yesterday we could see what the
european nations were talking about
we saw who is the real leader and who is
fighting for the unified europe who is
fighting for the joint european security
and who was trying to
stop us who was trying to stop you we
understand why
polls
know how to fight together with others
fight for freedom
for the european freedom for europe
remember
a huge strategy
tragedy that happened in 2010 in
smallisk
you remember how the circumstances of
this crash were investigated we
understand what it meant to you and what
it meant for you
to face the silence of those who knew
the circumstances very well
but we're still looking towards our
neighbor
our brothers and sisters
i feel that we have already built an
amazing alliance
perhaps informal yet
but this is an alliance that is based on
reality
not written on paper this is an alliance
that stems from the warmth of our hearts
and not from the words of politicians
at high levels
the way you accepted our friends our
people who are welcome in your homeland
where they sought refuge against this
evil that happened to our country there
is over 1.5
million of ukrainian citizens here and
they don't feel as foreigners here they
were accepted in families with the
spirit of brotherhood and kindness
and you don't want anything in return
you do it from the heart as between
friends as in the family which is why i
just uh appealed to you my friend andrei
uh dear agatha
can say that we have already united
ourselves
we united ourselves
like this great poll john paul ii said
that we will together
strive for freedom and create freedom
i am convinced
that we will be defending freedom
together
together with you
as much as we need to i am grateful for
your help that you have already provided
help from your state from your nation i
am grateful for all the efforts that you
make
to protect the ukrainian
airspace
i believe that we will manage
to
achieve something very important
god willing
if we win this war
we will share with you
our
victory we'll share it with our brothers
and sisters this is our greatness but
also your greatness
this is a battle for our freedom but
also for your freedom
this is a joint history of great nations
dear lord please let us win
you